AND THEY GOT THREE TEAMS IN
FRONT OF THEM MISSED BASICALLY.
TRIES TO SEPARATE HIS MANHANDLE
TIME AND ROOM. I SAW THE STICK
OWN
LIKE THAT HAS BEEN CONSISTENT
AND THEY'VE MOVED D  IS BACK
ON THE GOAL PARADE AFTERLIGHTNI
CENTER.HOCKEY LEAGUE.
THAT IS HIS 43rd GOAL AND WATCH
THEM TURN ON  OUT OF THE PILE B
HEDMAN.
CYCLES THE BACK AND WAITING FOR
>> Brian: THIS IS LIKE LINE
RUSHES YOU'RE E  HE BACKED
OFF AND WAS POINTING LIKE
ONE LAST TRIP UP THE ICE FOR
WINNIPEG ON THE POWER PLAY.
BELLEMARE
KILLORN.
THERE IS NO WAY HELLEBUYCK
SOLACE COMING UNTIL PROBABLY
WAS ONLY A
THAT.
IS NOT REALLY TO SHOT AND PUTS
IT INTO THE CORNER.
TOP INTO THE E
APPRECIATES A GREAT PLAY , IT
STARTED WITH PAUL HIT AND DIDN'
NEED ANYBODY TO HELP.
HE GOT RIGHT BACK IN SOMEBODY
FACE AND TURNEDEDSPLIT WIDE.
THAT HAD BREAKAWAY WRITTEN ALL
OVER IT FOR A SECOND.MOVEMENT I
THE GAME, A TURNOVER AT THE
BLUE LINE THAT HELPED,IT UP. /K
>> Brian: SERGACHEV WAS GETTING
SOSO